Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is
Not Allowed To Do At The Foundation:
No interacting with SCP-5555-J
under any circumstances!
SCP-5555-J is capable of reducing any
living organism to a miniature (or chibi,
if you’d prefer) version of itself.
Dr. Bright may claim he is trying to
make teacup pigs to hand out at the office
as an incentive, but do not fall for it!
The last time Dr. Bright
was exposed to SCP-5555-J,
the miniature version it produced of him was a
miniature orangutan. He was brought into custody,
and proceeded to behave quite poorly with some
of his own bathroom material, and completely
destroy the attending researcher’s clothing,
before escaping to wreak even more havoc.
Dr. Bright knows what mini-him did, and he
has lost his 5555-J privileges for good.
Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is
Not Allowed To Do At The Foundation:
Dr. Bright is not permitted to try and
solve every single problem with chainsaws.
Chainsaws can be quite helpful when
it comes to certain specific tasks!
They’re great at, for instance, speedily
chopping up lumber or menacing a group of
unsuspecting teenagers on a road trip.
However, Dr. Bright would like you to
believe that the application of chainsaws
goes far beyond the realm of reason or safety.
Chainsaws should not be used: To trim your hair,
to contain SCP-682, to cut a sandwich, or as the
ammunition in a specialized cannon. It was fine
the one time at the company Christmas Party,
we all had a good laugh, but Doctor Jones will
never get his big toe back. No more chainsaws!
Another Series of Things Dr. Bright Is Not
Allowed To Do At The SCP Foundation: Claim
he is from an alternate timeline, issue orders
to, quote, “preserve the timeline”, unquote,
or to, quote, “corrupt the timeline”, unquote, or
to, quote, “screw those history nerds, “ unquote.
Dr. Bright may be cursed to live for
a very long time, but he is still,
sadly, fundamentally attached to our
timeline. He may have watched Loki
recently, but that doesn’t mean he’s a
multi-verse galavanting trickster god.
He only wishes he was.
Another Thing That Dr. Bright Is Not
Allowed To Do At The SCP Foundation:
Dr. Bright is not allowed to apply SCP-963
to any major political figures. Again.
So we’ve got some background here. Anyone
who has seen our video on SCP-4444 will
know that a species of aliens almost
destroyed our planet in the year 2000
after they possessed presidential
candidate Al Gore. In order to stop them,
Dr. Bright needed to take over the body
of George W. Bush to run against him.
While this was an emergency where
certain risks needed to be taken,
our current geopolitical landscape is
already too wild and too fractious to
risk Dr. Bright ever rising to any kind
of political power. Though if he did,
he would probably run on the major campaign
slogan “C’mon, Guys, You’ve Had Worse!”
Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to do:
Dr. Bright can not give SCP-082 song requests!
SCP-082 loves to sing. If there's anything he
loves more than lying and feasting on human flesh,
it's busting out a cheerful little
tune from time to time. However,
as Dr. Bright has shown that he cannot
be respectful of SCP-082's tastes,
or the comfort of those working around him, he is
not permitted to request any songs from SCP-082.
Fernand was recently reduced to tears when
his rendition of a classic Italian aria was
interrupted by Dr. Bright's repeated
cries of "Do Free Bird!" and he also
expressed discomfort when Dr. Bright told
him to perform "Like a Virgin." He should
know by now that Fernand only likes to
sing one Madonna song, and it's "Vogue."
Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to do:
Dr. Bright is not allowed to "accidentally"
spill green gelatin on a dead body.
It is well known by SCP staff, particularly those
in the O5 council, that allowing SCP-447's green
slime to come into contact with a dead body will
result in disaster on a catastrophic scale. Of
course, Dr. Bright decided that it would be
hilarious to procure some lime jello from the
canteen, pretend to trip and fall, and spill the
gelatin all over a body being observed by the O5.
Admittedly, the first time, it was a bit
funny. But it was also extremely stressful,
multiple staff fainted, and O5-2 made
it a point to tell Dr. Bright that he
"owed him a new pair of khakis" after the
sudden terror had made him, well, ruin his.
Another thing Dr. Bright is not
allowed to do at the Foundation:
Dr. Bright is not allowed to Speed Date!
If you remember an event called SCP Speed dating,
please report to Site Command immediately
for your mandatory dose of Class A Amnestic.
This event never officially took place, and
there is no public record of it. Dr. Bright
certainly did not pack the canteen with safe-class
humanoid SCPs and employees of the Foundation, and
ding a bell every five minutes so that eligible
singles could switch tables and meet someone new.
There were no public displays of
affection on Foundation grounds,
and certainly no ensuing disastrous
dates at any local Italian restaurants.
Dr. Bright is not allowed to organize
a speed dating event ever again. Um,
I mean, for the first time. Because there
has never been one. Not here. No sir.
Another thing Dr. Bright is not
allowed to do at the Foundation:
He is not allowed to use
SCP-705 for personal gain!
The Play-Doh toy soldiers are highly entertaining
to watch, and it’s understandable to be curious
about their potential applications, but
Dr. Bright has taken it too far. He used
the tiny soldiers to plant hidden cameras
and microphones in his colleague’s offices.
Not only is this a violation of their
privacy, but it’s also just plain creepy,
and it’s unfair to make SCP-705 instances
accomplices to your bad behavior!
They didn’t know what they were signing
on to do, and if they’d known the hidden
surveillance equipment was intended for
blackmail or for stealing a secret lasagna
recipe that’s been in Dr. Giotta’s family for
generations, they never would have agreed.
Another thing Dr. Bright is not
allowed to do at the Foundation:
Dr. Bright is not permitted to assign the
designation “Over 9000” to any anomalies.
Dr. Bright is to be reminded that first of
all, the SCP Foundation does not track the
“power levels” of any of its anomalies,
as that is a completely subjective notion.
Adding “it’s over 9000” to official
Foundation documents is distracting,
and confusing, particularly when applied to
entities like SCP-999 who have no interest
in combat. Second of all, he should know that
joke hasn’t been relevant in over a decade, he’s
embarrassing himself and none of the new research
assistants even know what he’s referencing.
Finally, he’s not as good at doing
the Vegeta voice as he thinks he is.
Update your references, Dr. Bright!
You’re better than that! …Maybe.
Another Thing Dr. Bright Is Not
Allowed To Do At The Foundation:
When writing a report, more detail is
expected than "Object class: Keter.
Special Containment Procedures: [DATA EXPUNGED].
Description: [DATA EXPUNGED]." And inventing new
security clearances just so nobody can see what
you've written is also considered poor form.
We all know sometimes RAISA can
get a little redaction-happy,
we understand the frustration, but that’s frankly
no excuse to fill your documents with
nonsense and then hide them from us.
If you keep doing this, we’ll send
Technical Researcher Rosen after you,
and we both know that guy’s a huge
jerk. Mark our words, Dr. Bright,
we are not bluffing - even if you do claim
to have Security Clearance Level 420!
Another Thing Dr. Bright Is Not Allowed To Do At
The Foundation: Showing Monty Python episodes to
SCP-239 was not a wise decision. Please never
try this with any other reality-warping SCP.
Seriously, Dr. Bright. The Witch
Child is a reality warper so powerful
we need to keep her in a comatose state to stop
her from permanently reformatting our universe.
Do you really think it’s a good idea to
show her Flying Circus or the Holy Grail?
If we find that, by sheer coincidence, we
later need to contain an anomaly that shares
a remarkable resemblance to the Black Beast
of Argh, we know exactly who is responsible,
and we will not take this indiscretion lightly.
We might even make you sit on the comfy chair!
Another thing Dr. Bright is not
allowed to do at the Foundation:
Dr. Bright is Not Allowed to Kick SCP-2558-J!
SCP-2558-J refers to a group
of seemingly ordinary kittens,
who display friendly and affectionate
behavior toward humans and each other.
When startled or made to feel afraid,
the kittens inflate into a fluffy spherical
shape about the size of a soccer ball,
able to move around by rolling.
Dr. Bright is not permitted to kick
any of the kittens, whether they are in
their ball form or not. He is also strictly
prohibited from playing dodgeball, volleyball,
or any other ball-based game with SCP-2558-J.
The only way anyone is permitted to play with
the kittens is using the Foundation-sanctioned
cat toys provided upon request. For
crying out loud, man, they're kittens!
Another thing Dr. Bright is not
allowed to do at the Foundation:
Dr. Bright is Not Allowed to Play "Hippocratic
Oath Chicken" with the Medical Staff!
The Hippocratic Oath is deeply
important to all medical professionals,
including those on staff at the SCP
Foundation. Dr. Bright is not permitted
to try and convince the medical staff to
break the Hippocratic Oath in any way.
He is especially not allowed to expose them to
potentially dangerous anomalies while taunting,
"Still want to do no harm? You sure?" It's a waste
of time, resources, and it's just plain rude.
One of these days, they're going to
snap and slap him across the face
and not one of us will stop them.
Another thing Dr. Bright is not
allowed to do at the Foundation:
Dr. Bright! The Foundation Motto
is Not "Let's Use it on 682!"
Dr. Bright is to be reminded that the Foundation's
only official motto is Secure, Contain, Protect.
It is not, in fact, any of the alternatives he has
suggested. This includes but is not limited to:
"Can we put it in 914?"
"Blood makes the grass grow, kill, kill, kill!"
"Throw D-Class at it until it stops."
"When in doubt, feed it to 682."
"Slapstick, Clowns and Puns,"
or "Snap Crackle and Pop."
That last one got us served a cease
and desist from Kellogg's, and we
can't afford a lawsuit right now. Cut it out!
A note to all SCP Foundation staff: If Dr. Bright
has to ask, it's above his clearance level.
If it's above Bright's security clearance… run.
Dr. Bright is one of the SCP Foundation’s
most illustrious researchers, and as site
director of Site-19, there’s very little under
the Foundation's purview that he can’t do.
So if you find Dr. Bright is poking his stolen
nose where it shouldn’t be, then believe me,
you definitely shouldn’t be there. Think of
all the terrifying entities you know about
from the SCP Foundation files. Now imagine all
the horrifying things you DON’T know about…
Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed
to do at the Foundation: Dr. Bright is not
allowed to send e-mails with memetic hazards
attached! No, not even when replying to spam!
Dr. Bright. We don't care how annoying it is
when your inbox fills up with suspicious links,
Linda's annoying Quote of The Day,
and chain letters telling you that
you have to forward the email to 10
people or have bad luck for a year.
That doesn't make it okay to
reply with SCP-2774 attached!
That goes for any other memetic
hazard. The last thing we need is
more instances of these hazards
floating around in cyberspace.
Take a breath, stand up from the keyboard,
and let the spam filter do its job.
Another Thing Dr. Bright Is Not
Allowed To Do at The SCP Foundation:
Dr. Bright cannot use “My evil
twin did it” as a viable excuse.
The same goes for “My good twin did
it”, considering the implication.
Weirder things have happened at the SCP
Foundation than having an evil twin,
so maybe someone could make the excuse that their
evil twin committed some crime on their behalf.
But the Bright family is one of the most
well-known dynasties in Foundation history,
so nobody is going to believe that there’s a
hidden member of the family still out there.
Maybe if SCP-963 had a perfect
copy, you might have an excuse here.
But to the best of our knowledge, that
is not the case. Take your lumps, Jack.
Another Thing Dr. Bright Is Not
Allowed To Do At The SCP Foundation:
Dr. Bright is not allowed to use “For The
Emperor” as justification for any decision.
For starters, the SCP Foundation is independent
from the commands of any single nation.
It is an autonomous non-profit
organization, and you know that.
Secondly, the only country in the world
that still has an active Emperor is
Japan - and his role is purely ceremonial
because Japan is a constitutional monarchy.
And just for the record, “For the O5
Council” and “For The Administrator”
are also unacceptable unless the order
you’re acting on actually comes from them.
allowed to offer the solution of
"Use more guns" to any problem!
Dr. Bright. Look at me. We went over this before,
with the chainsaws. Do you remember?
Do we really need to do this again?
I guess so.
We face a wide variety of
problems here at the Foundation,
of varying degrees of severity. There is no
one-size-fits-all solution for these problems,
and even if there was, it would not be
"use more guns," or "get bigger guns."
This includes but is not limited
to: old-fashioned dueling pistols,
machine guns, or something called the
"octo-gun" which my notes say was just
eight guns taped together...? How does that even
work? Never mind, don't answer that. The point is,
it's not helpful. And Dr. Bright is not allowed
in the armory. Not even on his birthday.
The Ultimate Showdown
of Ultimate Destiny is
not grounds to pit more than fifteen
combinative SCPs against each other!
Okay, who let Dr. Bright log on to
YouTube unsupervised? Whoever it is,
you're in big trouble because Dr.
Bright watched The Ultimate Showdown
of Ultimate Destiny and it gave
him some pretty destructive ideas.
Watching Batman fight Godzilla made him think
about throwing another giant lizard into combat,
and he attempted to organize, in his
words, a Grand Tournament where fifteen
of the most powerful and violent SCPs would
battle each other in a makeshift coliseum.
This is not permitted, under any circumstances.
Yes, even if you film it and post it on YouTube.
Another Thing Dr. Bright Is Not Allowed To Do
At The SCP Foundation: Yes, forum trolls are
annoying. No, they don't automatically
become D-class personnel, Dr. Bright!
Personally, we’d think that someone who’s lived as
long as you - and died multiple times - would have
thicker skin. But your repeated insistence
to turn forumites like BootyHunter69 and
DankyDankyLiteratureClub420 into D-Class personnel
is as bizarre and sad as they are nonsensical.
People need to be truly despicable
to warrant having a place among the
ranks of D-Class personnel. They need to
be truly monstrous, evil, underhanded,
unethical, bottom-of-the-barrel individuals,
and frankly, forum trolls do not fit the bill.
YouTube Commenters, on the other hand…
Another thing Dr. Bright is not
allowed to do at the Foundation:
No placing pranks in new staff's desks
and liquefying them in "record time!"
Starting a new job can be a stressful experience.
Figuring out the office culture,
choosing a coffee cup in the break room,
and deciding which funko pops look best
on your desk, it's a lot to think about!
The last thing a new employee needs is to sit down
at their brand new desk, open a drawer to grab a
pen, and have their flesh melted from their skull
by a bright blast of mysterious green light. It's
not funny, we're not impressed anymore, and staff
turnover at the Foundation is already high enough
as it is. No more pranks, it's not a "right of
passage" if they don't survive it, Dr. Bright!!!
Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to do at
the Foundation: No unsupervised access to SCP-387!
SCP-387, or The Living Lego, is a miraculous
find. It is a tub of seemingly ordinary Lego
bricks that, when built into a shape by human
hands, comes to life and even develops sentience.
Of course, Dr. Bright can never let a cool thing
just exist without wreaking some havoc with it,
and decided to build a tiny lifelike model of
SCP-682. We have no idea how he built it so
fast, or why it took military-grade explosives to
blow apart a creature made from plastic blocks,
but it was a mess to clean up, and Agent
Johnson will never get his big toe back.
If Dr. Bright is so desperate to play with
Legos, he'll have to stick to the non-magic kind.
Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to do:
No bets concerning XK-Class
End of the World Scenarios!
It's the one thing we hope to
avoid: An XK Class Scenario,
an event that results in the complete
and utter destruction of the world.
Most of us prefer not to think about it at all,
unless we're actively trying to prevent it.
Not Dr. Bright, though. He sees the
apocalypse as a chance to make a quick buck!
Dr. Bright is officially prohibited from making,
accepting, or taking any rake-off bets related to
XK Class Scenarios. These include, but are not
limited to, "I'll bet you a thousand bucks the
robots get us first," "it'll all start with
ducks," and "not with a bang, but with a whimper."
Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed
to do: No showing bad movies to SCP-682!
SCP-682 is famous for a lot of things: its
indestructible nature, its insatiable appetite
for violence, and the overflowing well of hate
in its heart. Unsatisfied with SCP-682's ordinary
level of rage, Dr. Bright decided to take it upon
himself to give the lizard even more things to be
angry about, and organized an informal "so
bad it's good" film festival for the anomaly
and himself. The resulting damage, and loss of
life, cost the Foundation thousands of dollars.
Movies on the "do not show to 682 list" include:
The work of Uwe Boll, the work of Neil Breen,
The Room, Troll 2, Manos: The Hands of Fate,
and, let's face it, any other movie Dr.
Bright can think of. No more movies.
Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed
to do at the Foundation: Dr. Bright is
not allowed to classify any researcher,
including himself, as a memetic hazard!
Memetic hazards are not to be taken
lightly. Many of the SCP Foundation's
best and brightest have been cut down in
their prime by memetic hazards that ate
away at their sanity and destroyed their minds.
Just because Dr. Bright likes singing "The
Song that Never Ends" and annoying everyone,
that does not make him a memetic hazard by
Foundation standards. Other behaviors that
do not qualify a researcher as a memetic
hazard include but are not limited to:
whistling all the time, clipping their nails at
their desk, or microwaving fish in the break room.
Another thing Dr. Bright is not
allowed to do at the Foundation:
No claiming to be, or to
have ever been, Steve Irwin!
How dare you? Steve Irwin was an international
treasure, and you will never, ever
fill his sensible shoes, Dr. Bright. No matter
how much you say "crikey" when looking at SCP-682,
no matter how many times you call it a "mighty big
croc!", no matter how much you photoshop yourself
into photos of SCP-682 or how many Australians you
possess, you will never be The Crocodile Hunter.
Stop trying to make it happen,
no one is going to call you that.
And stop tricking interns into buying autographed
memorabilia from you, we all know it's a forgery.
Another thing Dr. Bright is not
allowed to do at the Foundation:
No changing the standard-issue D-Class uniform!
Dr. Bright is always proposing
changes at the SCP Foundation,
and nearly all of them should
be disregarded immediately.
The D-Class uniform is perfect the way
it is, and does not need to be changed.
It especially does not need to be changed
to black pants with a red polo shirt. We
get what you're going for, Dr. Bright. It's
very clever, we also enjoy Star Trek. But in
addition to it being a waste of resources
to produce all of those new uniforms,
we just don't want a lawsuit from
Paramount Global on our hands.
Another thing Dr. Bright is not
allowed to do at the Foundation:
No playing Hot Potato with SCP-963!
SCP-963 is the ornate, anomalous amulet that
contains Dr. Jack Bright's consciousness.
Any living subject that comes into contact
with this amulet ceases brain function,
and their consciousness is
replaced with Dr. Bright's.
If they remain in contact with the amulet
for longer than 30 days, they will retain
this consciousness even after the amulet has
been removed. Otherwise, they will experience
brain death. Essentially, it should be taken
incredibly seriously, and handled with great care.
It should not be tossed at a random D-Class,
Research Assistant, or any other Foundation staff
member with shouts of "CATCH!" or used to play any
other high-stakes contact-based game. It is not,
in fact, a "fun team-building exercise,"
that should be played on company retreats.